who's the flattening possible flattening
of the curve is better than the
increases that we have seen New York is
still far and away the most impacted
State New Jersey is having real
difficulty and been speaking with
Governor Murphy from New Jersey and
anything we can do together we will
Michigan also California has leveled off
and Louisiana is having a difficult time
so there there are now thoughts and
prayers total number of hospitalizations
are down the ICU admissions are down and
the daily intubations are down those are
all good signs and again would suggest a
possible flattening of the curve the
number of discharged is down but that
reflects the overall reduction in the
numbers big question that we're looking
at now is what what is the curve and
we've been talking about cases increase
increase increase until they don't when
they stop increasing then what happens
and the projection models have a number
of alternatives some suggest basically
the curve goes up and then drops
precipitously some suggest is a slight
pause at the top some suggest there's a
longer pause at the top which is
effectively a plateau effect or again
the straight up and straight down
precipitous drop which is the peak
effect no one can tell you which will
occur they say any one of the three
options you study other countries you've
had a combination of the above we are
studying it as we use the projection
models from day one to determine
actually what we do how do we set policy
and programmed by following the data dr.
Milano's has been working on the numbers
working with the statisticians and the
projection models and helping us
incorporate that into an operational
model and Jim if you want to just take a
moment and speak about the projection
models here please
great Thank You governor as the governor
said we have been looking at projection
models from the beginning to determine
the size and scope and severity and the
governor has mentioned this over his
briefings we've been working with many
organizations and using the data like
Imperial College the Institute for
Health metrics and evaluation Cornell
McKinsey and others and some of the
initial projections that we first saw at
the beginning of this was at least a
hundred up to 110 thousand beds for
kovat patients alone and the peak would
come at the end of April those were some
of the earliest modeling from many
organizations that it would be at the
end of April around a hundred ten
thousand beds just for kovat patients
there are other models too that we were
tracking one being lower at about 55,000
coated beds but again peaking at the end
of April we follow now that we have a
pretty robust data set to go by for the
last several weeks the bottom line there
the purple line is sort of where we are
tracking today which suggests it's a
little lower and the question was what
could you do to lower those initial
projections from 110,000 and from 55,000
so a lot of the activity was we saw
where two statisticians and the folks
looking at these types of models said it
was going so what activities and actions
could you take to aggressively lower
that overall number and the answer
really was and what the governor's been
doing was aggressively enforced and
enact social distancing to lower the
overall number and this number and the
current data suggest that that is
exactly what's happening
and it's not settled yet because we are
going day by day and the numbers as the
governor says has changed a lot over the
time based on what numbers come in but
this could suggest that we are indeed
potentially at the apex or beginning to
be at the apex at this moment like the
governor has said there's been a range
of models seven days 14 days 21 days 30
days it looks like we're at towards the
earlier side of that time frame based on
the current projections and modeling
that we've been looking at thank you Jim
but you also see on these you see on
this slide where we are now right and it
can still go anyway we could still see
an increase so it is hopeful but it's
also inconclusive and it still depends
on what we do right these models all
have a coefficient of what we do and how
successful we are social distancing etc
and from our decision-making point of
view it doesn't really matter if we've
hit the plateau or not because you have
to do the same thing if we are
plateauing we are plateauing at a very
high level and is tremendous stress on
the healthcare system and to say to this
health care system which is at maximum
capacity today right this is a hospital
system where we have our foot to the
floor and the engine is at redline and
you can't go any faster and by the way
you can't stay at redline for any period
of time because the system will blow and
that's where we are we are at redline
people can't work any harder the staff
can't work any harder and staying at
this level is problematic and if we are
plateauing it's because social
distancing is working so we have to make
sure the social distancing actually
continues on the relieving the pressure
on the hospital system which is
unsustainable at this rate we're
continuing what we call our surgeon flex
program where we get all the hospitals
on the line on a daily basis they're all
doing inventories they're all doing data
sheets they're all on the telephone and
we're shifting among the hospital's
ventilators PPE equipment who has gowns
who has masks and that happens on a
daily basis that adjustment also to
relieve pressure on the hospital system
the Javits coming online is a very big
deal that is the relief valve for the
entire downstate system the 1100
military personnel started to come in
300 were sent to New York City public
hospitals to help the New York City
public hospital system the HNH system
which has been under stress the rest
will be going to Javits to bring that up
and running to full capacity that
transition is happening now that B is a
co vyd Center now started as non kovat
it's now a covert Center the majority of
the military personnel will be coming in
tomorrow and the next day but that
Javits Center is going to be a major
relief valve second the United States
Navy ship comfort the original plan was
that that that would come in for non
kovat people the original plan was it
would also be a relief valve on the
hospitals but not for covert people that
it would take all the non-covered
patients if you will from the hospital
system that was the plan as it turned
out there's not a lot of non kovat
people in the hospital system which is a
separate story happens to be a good news
story a byproduct of shutting everything
down is you have fewer car accidents
crime rate is way down
fewer trauma cases so there's not there
is not a large non-covered population in
the
I'm gonna call the president this
afternoon and ask him to shift the
comfort from non-covered to kovat then
we would have jabots and the ship
comfort as a relief out this 2500 beds
and a thousand beds that's 3,500 beds
which could serve as a relief valve for
the whole downstate hospital system that
is the only way we sustain this level of
intensity in the hospital system and I
understand what the original plan was
with a comfort but I understand that
there is no preordained strategy here
you have to feel it out day to day and
you have to adjust with the facts and we
don't need the comfort for non kovat
cases we need it for kovat if we had
those two facilities as a relief valve
that would make a significant difference
now bringing online 3500 beds is no
small task northwell health is going to
help us manage those but they're going
to be staffed by military personnel only
the military could bring in that many
people that quickly with that logistical
operation and I want to thank DoD very
much for their cooperation because God
bless the US military we were fully
aware of what they do to defend this
nation but this is a different
application that we don't see every day
and they're doing an extraordinary job
so I'll call the president
he has been helpful to New York in the
past and he's moved very quickly in the
past I'm gonna ask him if he can make
this adjustment for us because it would
be truly beneficial we would feel much
better knowing that we can sustain this
pay pace if we could start to offload
patients to these two facilities in any
event Plateau not Plateau
we still have to extend New York pause
because if that curve is turning it's
turning because the rate of infection is
going down one of the reasons the rate
of infection is going down is because
social distancing is working we have to
continue the social distancing schools
and non-essential businesses will stay
closed until April 29th I know that's a
negative for many many reasons I know
what it does to the economy but as I
said from day one I'm not going to
choose between public health and
economic activity because in either
event public health still demands that
we stay on pause with businesses closed
and schools closed whether we've hit the
apex or whether we haven't hit the apex
you'd have to do the same thing there's
also a real danger in getting
overconfident too quickly this is an
enemy that we have underestimated from
day one and we have paid the price
dearly well the numbers look like they
may be turning yeah it's over no it's
not and other places have made that
mistake Hong Kong has made that mistake
South Korea has made that mistake and
we're not going to make that mistake the
weather is turning people have been
locked up we've been talking about cabin
fever now it's a nice day I'm gonna get
out I'm gonna go take a walk now is not
the time to do that and frankly there
has been a laxness on social distancing
especially over this past weekend
that is just wholly unacceptable look
people are dying people in the health
care system are exposing themselves
every day to tremendous risk walking
into those emergency rooms
then they have to go home to their
family and wonder if they caught the
virus and they're bringing it home to
their family if you don't if I can't
convince you to show discipline for
yourself then show discipline for other
people if you get infected you infect
someone else you go to an emergency room
you put a burden on all sorts of other
people who you don't know and who
frankly you don't have the right to
burden with your irresponsibility and
people especially in New York City the
level of activity is up they partially
the weather made it a nice day I
understand people have been locked up
for a long time
but now is not the time to be laughs and
it is a mistake we all have a
responsibility we all have a role in
this we said that from day one and we
have to respect the role that we play
because the role that we play is a
societal obligation that's how I see it
I want local governments to enforce the
social distancing rules the local
governments are charged with enforcement
I want them to enforce them and I want
to be frankly more aggressive on the
enforcement because all the anecdotal
evidence is people are violating it at a
higher rate than before so we're gonna
increase the potential maximum fine from
500 to 1000 dollars but it's not really
about the fine nobody wants the money we
want the compliance we are serious and
again if it's not about your life you
don't have the right to risk someone
else's life and you don't have the right
frankly to take a health care staff and
people who are literally putting their
lives on the line
and be cavalier or reckless with them
you just don't have the right and we
want to thank all of the people who are
getting us through this every day on the
very tough circumstances and we see the
illness rate among these essential
workers and we know the sacrifice
they're making and we should respect it
it's that simple
you have the first responders who are
out there your police officers are out
there the transit workers who have to
drive a bus and the train every day the
health care workers who are just doing
extraordinary work
so let's respect them and let's help
them we're also going to set up a fund
run by the Department of Health to
assist the health care workers with
expenses costs childcare etc I want to
thank blank Blackstone for making the
first contribution to that fund of ten
million dollars to assist the first
responders I hope other individuals and
corporations follow their lead we're
also very aware of the mental health
aspect of this situation and the stress
and the isolation that this has caused
and people are trying in their own way
to grapple with what this means and what
is the impact how do you rationalize
this situation and the mental health
aspect of it is very real headspace is
going to partner with New York they're
an app they're going to have content for
New York and free membership for New
York so we thank them but we also have
an emotional support hotline we have
thousands of mental health professionals
who have signed up to volunteer to
provide mental health services so we
want people to make sure they know about
that and it's available I talked about
perspective a lot maybe frankly because
partially I'm speaking to myself and I
had good conversation with my daughter's
last night Kara Michaela who very are
often wiser than I am and wiser than
their years
it's very hard to see the number of
deaths we're having it's frightening and
it's disturbing that amount of loss I'm
the governor of New York I see my job as
preventing that kind of disturbance and
negativity and loss for the people of
the state perspective you know we like
to think that we can control everything
we can't we like to think that we can
fix everything and fix all the problems
for people we can't the undeniable truth
here is that this virus is a deadly
enemy and we will lose and we are losing
people who are vulnerable to the virus
that can't be controlled
that can't be fixed why that's mother
nature that's a question that God can
only answer but control what you can do
what you can the challenge is to make
sure that we don't lose anyone who could
have been saved if our health care
system was operating fully don't lose
anyone who you could save that is a
legitimate ambitious goal of government
and that we have done so far that we
have done so far have we saved everyone
no but have we lost anyone because we
didn't have a bed or we didn't have a
ventilator or we didn't have health care
staff no the what people we lost are the
people we couldn't save not for lack of
trying
and not for lack of doing everything
that we could do as a society not only
as a government and as a health care
system so to the extent we can find
peace in that
helps me and we are still New York tough
and New York tough means tough but tough
in a New York sense also means
compassionate it means that we are
unified it means that we are loving
because if you're really tough they're
really tough guys they're tough enough
to show love and because we're smart and
that's how we're going to get through
this questions drug trial of hydroxy
chlorine and chlorine going we have
we're using we've allowed usage of the
hydroxychloroquine with the zithromax
packs pack in hospitals at their
discretion the federal government is
going to increase the supply to new york
pharmacies we had a 14 day limit on how
much you could buy because so many
people were trying to buy it if the
federal government increases the supply
to new york which they say they're going
to do then we could lift the 14-day
limit there are a lot of people who rely
on this who were relying on it people
with lupus etc the tests in the hospital
they won't say that they are they're too
short a period of time to get a
scientific report you know hospital
administrators doctors want to give have
a significant data set before they give
a formal opinion anecdotally you'll get
suggestions that it has been effective
but we don't have any official data yet
from a hospital or a quote-unquote study
which will take weeks if not months
before you get an official study is that
a fair statement
but not conclusive it sounds like on
which on that that type of treatment in
hospitals yeah there has been an atonal
evidence that it is promising that's why
we're going ahead doctors have to
prescribe but there are some people who
have pre-existing conditions where it
doesn't work or they're taking
medication that's not consistent with
this treatment but anecdotally it's been
positive we'll have a full test once
they have a large enough sample and data
set Jessie but anecdotally it's been
positive and if we get an additional
supply we can which the federal
government says they're going to send
I'm gonna mention it to the president
actually going to call him this
afternoon with the comfort if they
increase the supply we can lift the
14-day limit a lot of wild rumors but I
have not heard anything about the city
burying people in parks no no I didn't
know that there was an issue I haven't
heard that there was an issue has
anybody heard that this an issue this
city where's any issue but I talked to
New York City
I talked to New York City yesterday I've
not heard that this is an issue
they have not asked for any that they
have not gotten we're releasing 802 the
city is basically responsible for the
11h health and hospital Corporation
hospitals public hospitals there are 11
health and Hospital corporations 11
Health and Hospitals hospitals in that
system and I spoke to the head of the
system last night I'm going to speak to
he's going to be on a phone call at 1
o'clock dr. Mitch Katz he had all the
equipment he needed and I'm gonna speak
to him again at 1 o'clock so if they
need anything we'll get it to them 802
for the downstate area now every
hospital will say to you I am running
low on everything because they are low
on everything right when we do these
daily surgeon flex discussions nobody
there's no margin for error because we
don't have any margin forever error we
just don't have the supplies the whole
system is over capacity
so everybody is low on everything and if
they had a wish list everybody would
want you know stock pile and a reserve
in their own Hospital I get that we
don't have that luxury
I'm you know taking ventilators from one
hospital on a daily basis bringing them
to another and then shifting them back
and forth so every hospital can get
through this period that's why I say
it's unsustainable for us so we're doing
that with PPE equipment we're doing that
with ventilators we're doing that with
patients if we can systematically get
patients out of the hospital system into
jabots and the comfort then you can
relieve pressure on the whole system but
the system is running
at redline has been for days this is the
most intense management function that we
have ever undertaken so it's not here in
this situation it's not what they want
it's what they need that's what is it
everybody would want I want to have 100
ventilators on reserve I know it's what
you need and that we're doing on a
day-to-day basis but everyone has what
they need there is no one who said I'm
out of ventilators and I have a critical
need who hasn't gotten your call for
increases in cracks crackdowns on social
distancing but we're getting reports of
funerals and weddings in Orthodox Jewish
communities in Rockland County and in
Brooklyn still being attended by
hundreds of then they should enforce
some enforce the rule Jesse I don't care
if you're Orthodox Jewish Catholic
Christian Muslim I don't care what it is
not about religious observation these
will enforce it also but let a local
government it's a job of local
government to enforce I'm doubling the
fine it's my way of saying this is
serious this is serious what right do
you have to act irresponsibly in a way
that could get you sick or someone else
sick and then I have to send an
ambulance to pick you up and bring you
to an emergency room that's already
overburdened that doesn't have staff
doesn't have supplies doesn't have
ventilators because you were reckless
and irresponsible you don't have that
right and I have to talk to these health
care workers all day long
I talked to transit workers I talked to
first responders who truthfully nobody
wants to put themselves in these
situations and I don't blame them and
they're doing it out of passion and
commitment and public service none of us
has the right to be reckless
in our own behavior which compounds the
problem with dealing with now is not the
time to be playing frisbee with your
friends in the park it's just not now is
not the time to go to a funeral with 200
people look I'm living this with my own
family yes I understand
grieving and I understand how the
religious services can help with the
grieving process and I understand how
it's hard not to do that but as a
society the the risk is too great
enforce the law the localities have the
legal right and responsibility to
enforce the law my doing the penalty
raising the penalty is my way of saying
do it just do your job today we're
beyond capacity how much remains in the
state stop we're beyond capacity
we are into the plan BCD that we
outlined right we are into using BiPAP
machines instead of ventilators we're
into splitting ventilators turning two
into one with two sets of tubes we are
in two backup plans that we had the
stock pas I don't know I can get you the
number but we are over capacity for the
number of ventilators in the whole
system we're using BiPAP machines we're
using splitting etc the question though
why not if there are still ventilators
in the state stockpile why don't you
send them in New York to the city no we
don't have anyone who says they need
them now who doesn't have them but you
just said they're over capacity well
they're using the plan BCD we can't give
everybody a ventilator for every
situation we have nine
and BiPAP machines for example we're
using the BiPAP machines we're using the
other machines but we don't have anyone
who says the 802 that we're sending
today represents the number that people
say they need now we extended the
deadline
the voting and filing deadline so I
don't know what else legally that we
could do and extend the deadline you'd
have to cancel elections period for the
year and I don't think we're in that
position
we've expend extended the use of
absentee ballots patience our portions
of nursing homes being set aside to
treat Kovac patients we're working with
the nursing homes and trying to cohort
patients within the nursing homes
remember this is something which we've
identified multiple nursing homes across
the state when within those nursing
homes were working to make sure that we
minimize the spread of the Cova disease
within that place that facility what
doctors are saying is when you have a co
vyd patient who had has been in that
facility they're trying to isolate the
kovat patients on one side of the
facility we're not using a nursing home
to treat colvett people we're not
bringing you a covered person into a
nursing home
and we're hearing that people who are on
the hook to pay child support or spousal
support who are out of work are having
difficulty coming up with the money can
estate help them out in any way
the Labor Department website the
unemployment website there's you know
yeah so we've now partnered with Google
we're gonna be releasing a new interface
by the middle of this week they've moved
from five-day week hotline to six day we
could live there now seven day a week
headline they have expanded the hours
we've gone from four servers to 50
servers they're in there trying to do
the Q by last name so that if you're
between a and D you call on Monday and
separating them out to try to manage
some of the volume but just so everyone
understands at the peak of the 2008
crisis in this the single largest day of
claims was thirteen thousand and one day
we had six times that two days ago so
this volume is something that we've
never experienced before and it's
frustrating and it's horrible and it's
unacceptable but we just ask that people
Romi impatient and we are working at it
we just put 300 more people in addition
to the 700 people that were manning the
call system so we are trying to do
everything we can to attack this issue
and most importantly you will get your
benefits going back to the date of your
actual unemployment even if there's a
lag and being able to get signed up for
the benefits
I haven't even looked at their decision
on the regions it sounds right but I
haven't even looked at I don't know you
know New York City localities make
decisions on their own on local issues
so I have no reason I don't have any
opinion on what the mayor did I just
don't know the facts well enough on that
program the social distancing we have
again hopeful news in the in the data
that could be slowing plateauing turning
but it's also dependent upon what we do
and how we handle ourselves and we know
that social distancing is important
that's why I'm extending the ban on
keeping businesses closed extending the
ban on schools but people
it's individual behavior that is been
problematic over the weekend I get that
it was a nice day and the weather was
good and people have been cooped up I
get it I get it all I'm living it just
like everybody is living it but we get
reckless we change or we're not
compliant on social distancing you will
see those numbers go up again that's why
I showed you the Hong Kong the China
experienced they let their foot off the
gas too quickly and we have been behind
on this virus from day one and this
virus has kicked our rear end and we
underestimate this virus at our own
peril we learned that lesson now is not
the time
to slap off on what we're doing one more
question
we are moving ventilators now among the
system when someone has a change in
patient load and they have additional
ventilators we move ventilators but we
have moved thousands and thousands of
ventilators throughout the system we've
acquired thousands and thousands of
ventilators I also want to thank Oregon
for sending ventilators I'm going to
thank the state of Washington for
releasing ventilators and suggest that
they be sent here I'm going to thank
California that also this morning
released ventilators because they
thought that they could be helpful to
New York that is the right attitude
that's the only way we do this as a
nation we're going to have to be
flexible and handle the surge as it
moves across the country that's just
what we're doing here in this state
surges in Nassau of one night we move
assets to Nassau surges in Rockland we
move assets to Rockland so that's the
only way we're going to do it because
the federal or the federal stockpile
federal stockpile if the federal
stockpile has 9,000 ventilators or
10,000 ventilators that's not going to
do it's not going to be enough for a
nation right so you're gonna have to get
States cooperating and shifting and
moving within the country New York will
be first on that list as soon as we get
through this and we have any flexibility
in our system we will be there for every
other state like they have been there
for us and we will lead the charge the
way we always have Hurricane Katrina we
were the first ones down there right so
when anyone needs anything we're there
and right now
health care wide I'm gonna get on the
phone with the hospitals now there is no
hospital that needs ventilators that
doesn't have ventilators there's no
hospital that needs PPE that doesn't
have it within the state system again
they're all going to say they're running
low because they are but nobody has
nobody doesn't have what they need to do
their job and that's my point on
perspective are we are we managing this
situation the best that can be managed
yes
have we lost anyone who we could have
saved I don't believe so
and with that we can sleep at night
I have to go to work thank you guys
[Music]
released ventilators we got 1,000
ventilators from China so right now okay